there's an old quote i'm not going to
attempt to remember it i'll butcher it
but the essence of the quote is
if you win the war then you you
earn the right to tell the history of
what happened
those those who are those who are the
storytellers are the ones who are
winners winners write history oh yeah
what's that the winner's right yeah yeah
there you go you got it yeah
um and that's powerful that's powerful
if you can just kind of
set the narrative set the foundation of
what actually happened and how it
happened
who your heroes are and who your
villains are
that's a great place to be and i think
two two people realize that
very clearly michael jordan
realized that and that's part of the
reason that he had a lot of hands
uh and i said that intentionally a lot
of hands his and others
in the last dance and he was he made
sure he told that story
the way he perceived it and
and i think scottie pippen and horace
grant
also realized that mj
was in control of the narrative and they
didn't like it because they realized how
powerful that was for jordan to be in
that position
knowing his status before the last dance
even existed
he had legendary status i mean i got
some of these shoes right around here
somewhere
you got his shoes uh i might have some
some gatorade and some haynes and
everything else
mj is an icon if mj said it happened
that's the way it happened
scottie pippen is not an icon and i can
understand mike
why he is so uh disappointed
by what he saw from the last dance
what do you why why why why scotty
pippen
why are you i mean you you've spoken
broadly but put yourself in scottie
pippen's
rather large shoes why why are you
disappointed by the last dance
because i feel like i saw what he saw
what he said i mean i don't know
do we have his quote handy you want to
read his quote or but go ahead oh just
give me your perspective though
why am i disappointed okay just i'm
gonna take your exercise i
put myself in scottie pippen shoes and
one thing
that i've come to realize is i played
with
for my money the greatest player of all
time and michael jordan mm-hmm
and and i know what that was okay i'll
get back to scotty
let me read this quote read the quote
yeah go ahead i don't think it was that
accurate in terms of really defining
what was accomplished in one of the
greatest eras of basketball but also
by two of the greatest players there's a
there's a key right there there's a
little hint
of how i feel and one could even put
that aside and say the greatest team of
all time
i didn't think those things stood out in
the documentary
i thought it was more about michael
trying to uplift himself
and to be glorified i think it also
backfired to some degree that people got
a chance to see what kind of personality
michael had well
uh so we'll get to that in a second i'm
scottie pippen
it's kind of what he said there i know i
play with jordan
i'm gonna be underrated that's just a
fact i'm gonna be underrated
and and i'm gonna i'm gonna be i'm gonna
go places i'm gonna go places that i
probably couldn't have gone with anybody
else
uh my greatness will be minimized to a
degree
because i play with jordan i'll get some
credit for being alongside jordan those
championship years
but overall me the individual i'm not
going to get my props
most people won't realize it but i tell
you who will realize it
a guy i played with named michael jordan
he knows what i did for him
a guy i played for phil jackson he knows
and most people other people won't know
but jordan should know
and the fact that jordan kind of he did
mike he did he did
scotty's right he did make it about him
it was it wasn't the last dance of the
chicago bulls
it was michael jordan's yet another
addendum yet another post script for
michael jordan
to tell you what you saw even though you
saw it i'm going to tell you what you
really saw
and it was all about me it was about
jordan and that's disappointing
i would be just what should it have been
about i guess
he would stop just still hold up stop
what was your build ass
what was it build at the 96
bulls or 98 excuse me the 98 bulls
might kind of start off like that
michael michael come on michael
okay no i'm not gonna come on i'm not
going here with you
there it is there there i sat here and i
listened to all of that
and respectfully i'm reading i'm
listening to scotty pip and i'm like
scottie save it okay
this is his lot in life and it ain't so
bad
okay number one scottie pippen was
named to the 50 greatest players in nba
history list
scottie pippen okay he's still on it
if you want to update it he's still on
it scotty pippen
is the patron saint of sidekicks
scotty pippen is the if you look up
oh i'm not gonna do that scottie pippen
is the definition
of the ideal wingman okay everybody who
knows
anything about basketball even in a
casual basket
no i'm not being dismissive hold on i'm
not being missing anybody
to the greatest player ever sorry
somebody gotta be
to the greatest player ever sorry okay
what's insulting about that what's
insulting about being the second
greatest player on the team that include
the greatest player ever come on man
we got to be on the road now
robin saved the day sometimes robin
saved the day
okay hey listen it's it's okay
somebody has got to you hey man you got
to be my sidekick it ain't that bad is
it
you know it's okay nothing wrong with it
right
you still get your shots you're still on
tv
right yo just heavy come on now let's
give you 100 let's give it a book
let's get it
your camera gonna go out any moment
no but i'm serious no but seriously i'll
just decide let's give it a scotty
pepper though
i love i love all right let's go back to
scotty yeah
yeah scotty listen man there is
there's an opportunity to be celebrated
if you're underrated
like everybody who knows anything about
basketball
even casual fans know that michael
jordan didn't win
anything without scottie pippen they
know that he's a greater defender
as michael he didn't i know he didn't
but
and he wouldn't have won anything
without scottie pippen and
his greater defender michael jordan was
as great as
everybody knows that especially after
the last everybody doesn't know there's
greater difference as michael jordan was
everybody who knows anything about
basketball knows that the better
defender was 33 not 23
as great as jordan was so i mean
those that know know and that which is
understood need not be explained
and so if scotty is looking first of all
i'm kind of in this business a little
bit so i'm speaking from a little bit of
experience
i'm in this business just a little bit
the business of selling content
of making documentaries and selling it
ain't nobody buying the scottie pippen
documentary with all due respect right
ain't nobody checking for a scottie
pippen documentary a scotty flipping
documentary
is not appointment viewing a michael
jordan documentary is
okay he's the headliner there's nothing
wrong with being morris date to his
prince
there is nothing wrong with that
nobody's arguing that's the argument
and guess what you know who came out
looking great in the last dance
pippen no way yes it was god
he obviously doesn't agree with that he
doesn't think so he would say
i'm telling him as a viewer i'm as a
viewer
that everybody was sympathetic to how he
got screwed over contractually
and you know who looked bad in the last
dance was michael jordan
for even in hindsight not taking up for
scottie pippen and understanding
how underpaid scottie pippen was funny
that scotty
was a sympathetic thing you're in this
documentary
that's funny to me that you would say
right now
that michael jordan didn't take up for
scottie pippen way back in 1998
when the guy didn't have the contract
that he was looking for
but if you're the greatest player of all
time
and you've got everything like you're a
billionaire you got
ads you got you're still in you didn't
play a game in 17 years
and you're still very active in the
in the greatest player of all time
debates people are are
are standing up for michael jordan in
these debates even those who didn't see
him play
live right he is still a cultural
icon you mean to tell me you can't throw
me more bones than you did
you do really need to be the hero that
much
where you it's got to be all about
michael it's like all about him it was
but
but but but i'm talking about specific
to the contract michael
there were plenty of times in the
documentary they just didn't get the
headlines
where michael gave scotty props gave
scotty love
it was and scotty was was celebrated in
his in his story his amazing
origin story this hero's origin story
was highlighted for a broader audience
in a way that it maybe never was
look the last dance had to be about
michael jordan just like
the nba since michael jordan and during
his heyday was about michael jordan
he drove the bus but scotty pippen was
very much right alongside him and
everybody recognizes that
i'm just not sure what more scotty wants
at this point we can't give him the
money that the bulls should have paid
him back then
everybody recognizes scotty's greatness
and if you don't you don't know a damn
thing about basketball
but that's okay because there were some
people there were some people who were
michael jordan fans
and this is this happens with a lot of
people who just have this these
charismatic personalities and it's just
larger than life
there were michael jordan fans who
weren't necessarily basketball fans
they were chicago bulls there were
people who followed the bulls and
followed jordan
but maybe not getting into the nuances
of what made the bulls great they just
saw michael jordan is there
and that's good enough it's like
watching some great like international
soccer star
i don't know the game but uh i'm going
to watch him
i'm going to watch messi and i don't i
don't know what i'm watching but i know
i'm watching greatness everything else
that's happening i can't tell you about
formations
he's there look which is why the boy's
documentary had to be
centered around him it could not be your
horse's grand car
there's a 98 bulls and everybody got
equal billing and everybody got equal
air time no
it's michael jordan michael jordan got
him six rings
and everything that came with that so
this documentary is michael jordan's
you just said it you just said it
default michael jordan
got y'all those six rings see what i'm
saying see hey if i pop scotty
like wait a minute wait a minute stop
attacking all right all right okay
i'm telling you asked me to be scotty
and that's what he's upset about
like let's just calm down with michael
got the six
not michael goddard not alone not alone
not alone i'm not saying he got it alone
michael come on you know
you know what exactly what i'm saying
you know exactly what i'm saying
scotty knows you know what horse grant
how many words are you calling the last
dance
what you know what you know what horace
grant called the last at last dance what
i'll say a song
called so-called documentary and he kept
saying it over and over
so-called documentary because we all
know that's what he said
we all know some stuff in there wasn't
true
cool but it was just they didn't check
the checks cash from orlando
did those checks cash from orlando
or not like i mean come on man like
this this the the golden goose yes
history is written by the winners i love
scottie pippen
i had a jordan jersey and a pippen
jersey
growing up maybe it's because i hold
skydiving in such high regard until i
didn't need the last dance
to educate me about the greatest scottie
pippen so maybe i got a blind spot there
because i saw him play and appreciate it
and play and appreciated how brilliant
he was when jordan stepped aside
but okay scotty when they asked him
directly when he wouldn't go back into
the game
when phil jackson drew up the play for
tony ku coach
what did scotty say in 2020 he wouldn't
have done anything differently
oh that was bad okay exactly you know so
it ain't like they didn't interview
scotty
it's not like it wasn't a part of the
documentary he was in it
prominently they interviewed well
yeah and well then you know okay that's
what well a couple of things one i'm not
gonna defend the thing on the final shot
that was really bad
i mean this it was bad at the time
it's still bad i can't believe he
actually did that scotty was an mvp
candidate when michael left
help yeah freddie gibbs said stuff was
different when mike left and it was
scottie team
freddie gibbs child now scotty pippen
and scotty b
how about that please go listen to
alfredo i need you to listen to alfredo
and scotty b
freddie gibbs makes a scottie flipping
reference i listen to a little bit of it
i just got being right i'm busy still i
got to be in the right space
now i got i got all kinds of time for
written testimony
i got all kinds of time for that hey
thanks for watching brother from another
on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you